hello and welcome to the new world
review and actually welcome to the final
new world review video of the year and
today I don't think there's a more
fitting topic than to get into the ever
intriguing discussion of will Hunter
hunter be returning in 2020 I'm not
going to lie this discussion does born
from a really terribly dark place that I
like to refer to as 2019 and rather
sadly this year became the first since
hunter hunt began serialization that not
a single chapter was published and this
is super disappointing because even
though hunter hunter is always on this
never-ending period of hiatus there was
actually some regularity two chapters
being published and with the exception
of the previously most awful 2013 fans
could count on roughly nine or ten
chapters a year at least on average I
guess sometimes much more sometimes less
and it should be noted that in 2013 only
two chapters were published which is a
pretty abysmal yet somehow much more
preferable amount than what 2019 has
delivered but even though this is the
worst hiatus period for hunter hunter
this is not the first time that we as
fans have experienced such despair every
time the series takes a hiatus we are
all met with that same sinking feeling
the unknown of when the series will
return and the looming thought this time
it may be the end because there is never
guarantee the serialization will restart
and it's such a sad state of affairs
because it always reminds us of exactly
how much potential hunter Hunter had as
a series for some insane perspective it
began serialization a mere year after
one piece began you know one piece the
world's third highest selling comic book
having run for 22 years and completely
revolutionizing Shonen manga as we know
it well hunter hunter back in the day
was a series that was supposed to give
one piece of run for its money and for a
while it absolutely did these two shown
in series formed a powerhouse block
alongside other contemporaries such as
Naruto and bleach but hunter hunter
despite remaining incredibly popular
would come to fade from the limelight as
the other series I've mentioned went on
to become the big three and as for
Hunter hunter the period of hiatus
hiatus began and now this is where we
cut to the comment section either
wishing Takashi all the best for his
health issues or cursing him for being
lazy and prioritizing playing Dragon
Quest over fulfilling his commitment to
the fans or any number of other theories
that have been perpetuated by the
staggering silence over the years and
unfortunately there's really nothing
anyone
can provide to solidify a reason as to
why the hiatuses keep happening although
the most legitimate piece of information
we do have is to Gashi citing that he
has chronic back pain and claims to be
completely bedridden at times and yes I
can see how that would make drawing
manga you know just still a little bit
difficult to say the least and there are
a bunch of conspiracy theories out there
posting photos of takashi at social
gatherings and calling him a blatant
liar but i really disagree with that
train of thought having health issues
does not mean that you could never go
outside or put yourself together enough
for a couple of hours for an important
event
although here's the thing even if both
Takashi and Shu a ship were lying for
the sake of saving face I am mostly in
the camp that toga she doesn't
necessarily us anything although I will
present the counter-argument for this
later because I also think that's a very
important discussion but it pains me to
say this as a massive hunter hunter fan
because seeing the series reach its
conclusion or at the very least being
able to explore the Dark Continent even
a teeny tiny bit are both high on up
there for the things I want most in this
world but in the end if toga she doesn't
have the pure drive to create Hunter
hunter anymore then the sad fact is that
it may be better off never being
finished and I say that as someone who
very much lives on the mantra of only
doing things when you feel like you want
to do them because generally I find that
if I force myself into things and my
work suffers significantly from the
half-assed effort I put into it and I do
not want that to be hunter hunter and we
do also know that mental strain plays a
huge part in togarashi struggles along
with his health issues being a mangaka
is one of the most hellish jobs I have
ever heard detail the hours are
absolutely insane and the deadlines
would drive most people mad within a few
months if not weeks
in fact Takashi even stated himself that
for the last few months of publishing
uhok sure he hadn't lost all emotional
attachment to the series due to a
combination of his body a change in
perspective on the art form of manga and
rather simply the desire to do something
literally anything else that was not
work and to call that lazy I don't think
is particularly fair because I don't
think any of us can really imagine just
what it is like to operate in Japanese
society at the highest levels with these
kind of expectations there's a reason
why Japan has an alarmingly high suicide
rate luckily for Takashi low due to
creating two of the biggest hit series
in manga history he's made more than
enough money that most of us could ever
dream of and is under no obligation to
continue working and making the concept
of his own happiness a background
feature although that
does open up a new avenue of discussion
which is that with such financial
security or more accurately quite a
lavish lifestyle it can be said that you
may want to consider the fans who read
and bought your work to put you in that
position and what I mean by this is at
the very least regular communication
about the status of the series and how
he's currently doing and I know in
polite Japanese society that sort of
openness is probably frowned upon but at
times the silence is really deafening
so does Takashi owe us anything well as
I stated before no I don't think he does
but I do question the decisions he has
made in regards to Hunter hunter despite
that belief for example I can accept
that his health is so bad that it
prevents him from drawing the large
majority of the time and when he can
it's just nowhere near enough to really
rival his former quality and whether
that doesn't necessarily prevent him
from writing and perhaps using his
infinite wealth to hire an artist or
even an army of artists to put Hunter
hunter into the best possible production
it could be in fact I'm certain that
chewy sure itself would gladly hire an
artist if no gosh she went down that
route because publishing hunter hunter
is just like printing money for them and
it's really amazing how its popularity
has just remained over the years despite
everything really is a unique series but
the only real reason I see Fateh akashi
not to invest in such an endeavor is
because of some sense of ownership over
the series which to be fair he does have
but it might be a sort of pride that he
can't possibly let anyone touch it
except for him lest it be tainted and
that is fair enough to some degree I get
that I really do but at a certain point
I do think that a level of sacrifice is
required and some responsibilities taken
this is not a situation that anybody
wants takashi does not want to hand over
his manga to anybody even if it is for
purely aesthetic work and the fans who
made and continue to make him a very
wealthy individual do not want to keep
living with hiatuses so I honestly don't
see a good argument for not bringing on
an external artist I mean there are the
following schools of thought either
Takashi is so passionate about the
series that he cannot bear to relinquish
any form of it in which case surely his
love for the series and desire to
deliver it would suspend that or Takashi
has lost the passion for hunt hunter or
intermittently loses passion in which
case there is no reason to care about
another artist taking on your workload
and so I've reached a point where it
honestly does become a bit hard to
defend the current state of Hunter
hunter the only argument I have is the
one I made earlier in the video where if
Togo she has lost passion for it then
maybe it's not worth continuing series
with great
and mediocre writing I don't know it
really is a tough one what we do know is
that Takashi has stated that he would
like to finish Honda hunter
I mean sadly the statement comes from an
interview in mid 2018 so who knows what
has happened since then he did say
though that it has either come to the
point where either the story concludes
first or he dies first
which yes those are the only two
possible options available kind of a
redundant thing to say really but that
statement is recent enough that it does
give me some weird sense of hope
although I don't know if that is just me
having learnt to live in an abusive
relationship with this series from my
personal perspective I can definitely
say being a hunter hunter fan is
incredibly frustrating at times because
I am eagerly sitting here being like I
want to explore your world I want to
watch your characters and their stories
play out and I want to pay for the work
that you publish only to be met with
complete silence and to never be given
any indication of progression until an
official announcement is made so I do
wish that tokachi could be more
transparent about the situation because
then at least we might be able to
achieve some sort of sense of
understanding but that said we also do
need to remember that hunter hunter is
just one series really weird to say
because essentially at this point I have
an entire channel based on it but there
are other much more important things in
life to invest time and passion into
Plus it's not as if never having more
chapters is a net loss in the end this
series has still given us an exceptional
amount of content that managed to
capture our attention in the first place
hunter hunter is a gem amongst the
Shonan genre even if it never gets
completed it's a very unique existence
that has been generated from over two
decades of evolution and growth words
author constantly pursuing new and
interesting ways of pushing what was
once a simple battle mark I highly doubt
we will ever see something quite like
hunter hunter again and I am very
grateful for the time I have spent with
it so far but with that said come on
2020 I know you can do it every week at
this point sets a new record for the
longest hiatus period so we must be
coming to the end of this dark tunnel
eventually right a logical thought there
of course but one that is somewhat
comforting I'll tell you what though
regardless of the state of the manga
this channel will continue producing
Hunter hunter content in the hopes of
drawing in new fans reigniting the
passions of old fans and providing even
a hint of satisfaction to that hunter
hunter craving that I know we all have
and that pretty much does it for the new
Walt review for 2019 if you've made it
to the end of this video then I'd like
to
extend a particularly special thanks for
making this a phenomenal first year in
the life of the channel they never
anticipated that the desire to seek
content made for a series not currently
in publication would be so high but I
really have been inspired by the love
you all share for Hunter hunter in
particular and it has been an honor and
a privilege to share that with all of
you so if you have any particular topics
you'd like me to cover in 2020 then
please do feel free to drop them in the
comments below because I am very keen to
continue exploring the depths of this
series because it really does provide so
much more than even I remembered but if
you enjoyed this video and the content
this channel produced in general then
please do consider donating to the new
worldview patreon because the support of
all of your amazing people is what
continues to make this channel possible
and if patreon isn't quite your style
then please do leave this video a like
share or subscribe because it also helps
plot this channel an incredible amount
and if you'd like to join the fun at any
time and please do head over to my
discord server where a wide array of
shenanigan tree takes place on a daily
basis and finally please do comment with
your predictions on when hunter hunter
will return this has been the new world
review and I'll see you next year
will you make your own inabilities I
would be real interested in seeing it
yes so this is something I've actually
been thinking about for a while now I'm
just not really sure how much actual
interest it would generate because it
wouldn't be about hunter hunter directly
but more like a theoretical exercise and
creating a couple of hot suit based on
my own personality and general needs in
life I personally think it's a really
cool idea in fact I think everyone
should do it I'm just not convinced that
it would make the best video who do you
think would win in a fight
illah me oh hey Sokka mmm and shrieking
question one that could probably have a
whole video dedicated to it really and
although it's pure speculation my gut
feeling would have to say Hisoka
certainly after the heavens' arena
incident now that he has invoked a form
of post-mortem n'en essentially giving
him a straight-up powerup before that
though I wouldn't be so sure so you know
give me some time to think about this
one
sounds like a 20/20 problem to me why
are people stupid while a person is
smart hmm so as a self identifying
people I don't feel in any way qualified
to answer this question